[Music]
hello hello hello thank you for coming
everyone my name is deep Kapadia I am
the executive director for delivery
engineering at the New York Times I'm
here with my colleague Prashant we're
here to tell you a story about the New
York Times we decided to move to the
cloud a couple of years ago and we've
entering a really interesting journey
and if you're thinking about what the
New York Times is doing New York Times
was doing in the cloud we're we're
traditionally a newspaper but today we
do a lot more things besides publishing
a newspaper and I wanted to show you a
one-minute clip of some of the things
that we do on an ongoing basis and let
er rip hey hey sorry so I got the folks
here at Kinkos to let me use the phone
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's it for the deal
I'm Michael barber see you tomorrow
okay sorry so sorry
transitions are a problem so you saw a
lot of things in that video and I think
what is what stands out is the fact that
the way we produce and showcase
journalism today is very different from
what we used to do like maybe 20 years
ago so there's a lot of products that
you saw or a lot of things that you saw
in the clip and it is important to know
that we're we've transformed from being
a newspaper to being a full-fledged
media company which is which requires a
lot of Technology and engineering
prowess to actually continue running and
we continue to experiment with new ways
of telling stories so like you know you
saw it snapchat Discoverer augmented
reality a lot of those things require
like a lot of engineering manpower to to
run but also a lot of compute a lot of
understanding of how how to serve the
content that is at large scale so I want
to talk to you about like what it means
to do that and why did we go down the
path of moving to the Google Cloud what
was what did our plan look like how do
we have how did we go through some
process and culture shifts some of the
lessons learned and also a little bit
about what we are working on today so so
this is where we started so if you if
you were to look at the the image here
this was our first ever homepage in
November 1996 and then and and if you
can read the line at the bottom it says
please open your window to the width of
the line of this text so clearly not a
responsive design it was it was mostly a
gift with an image map where you could
click through into stories and we've
come a long way from there as you saw in
the video clip today the website
nytimes.com the main website runs on GAE
it's a managed kubernetes platform by
google there's there have been a lot of
talks including the keynote about it we
embraced a lot of cloud native ways of
deploying and building stuff that
allowed us to move faster and we shut
down our data centers this year in April
so we don't have co-located data centers
where we run our website out of and this
is this is what it looks like today the
homepage you don't need to open it to
the width of the line of some text we
are responsive like we look a little
resize but the homepage is a fairly
complex mishmash of content but and also
we we have our article pages our
Interactive's and graphics that's one we
did for the 2016 election so for special
events we do special apps to tell
stories in a specific way there's new
new products that we've built along the
way like our cooking app we've always
had recipes and in the newspaper that we
brought together and like you know the
cooking app where people can share
annotate recipes and things like that
the Crossroads app has a life of its own
it is our highest grossing product and
it's a very popular one as well so all
the things that I'm talking about
require a lot of things behind the
scenes we're talking about api's we're
talking about it guys that manage our
content our content management systems
that the newsroom uses to to actually
write and build these experiences the
consumer revenue side of things where we
manage subscriptions and make sure that
like we're also reporting on those are
archives or archives as are a great
source of research for institutions and
students and professors and researchers
alike and then lastly our mobile
platforms our mobile apps like the way
people consume content is changing so
mobile apps are equity for us
but there were a lot of challenges to
get from where we were to where we are
as of two years ago the the challenges
listed here are pretty much challenges
that a lot of technology organizations
face as the landscape is shifting the
New York Times had a website in 1996
surprisingly it's it's it's been in
existence online longer than Google has
been so we had an IT team that was
actually just managing that website
which was a very simple gift that
someone would upload and like an image
map that people could flick through into
like a larger infrastructure team many
many product teams organic growth
sprouted lots of products and platforms
everyone was doing things a little bit
differently sometimes significantly
differently and that's difficult to
scale especially when people start doing
things differently it becomes very hard
very quickly to move faster like you you
you tend to build silos and you tend to
work in silos and anytime you have to
work across silos it becomes very very
hard for you to move as a result a lot
of these a lot of the apps that we were
trying to push out were basically a
spaghetti or a mishmash of architectures
that people put together to work around
some of the constraints because the IT
infrastructure team was very small and
it couldn't scale very fast and the big
the big the big problem we had is that
we had to move very very fast I mean we
wanted to move at the speed at which
Google's Facebook and our other
competitors are able to move at today
and that was becoming harder and harder
so we decided we and we talked long and
hard about this so what we decided to do
was form a team that would evangelize
best practices and also build common
tooling for engineers kind of like what
Google does for for all their other
clients but we did we decided really
very early on that this was not a team
that would run your infrastructure for
you so if you were a web app like you
couldn't like lob a web app over the or
all to an infrastructure team and say
like oh please run it and scale it for
us we would ask teams to do that but we
would provide the teams with the support
and the tools needed to do that and we
would help teams build the operational
maturity along the way and we would
manage some common tooling along the way
so like everyone needs to build and
deploy applications everyone was talking
about continuous integration continuous
deployment you need something to do that
you need something to manage secrets you
need you need a common way for you to
build stuff you also need to build
maturity as a part of your site
reliability engineering practice so so
we would work with teams to help them
understand a sorry practices build
tooling monitoring etc and also a lot of
test automation which means building
tools for tester for testing and
integrating those tools with your CI CD
pipeline so that was sort of the mandate
around which this team was formed and
evolving over the course of the last two
years and I'll let Prashant talk about
how we actually implemented some of the
changes that I just mentioned thanks
Steve so as Steve mentioned there were
challenges we were seeing and we formed
le ray engineering to solve that problem
now I'm going to talk about how we saw
migration as an opportunity to solve
solve those challenges and I'll walk you
through like what services we chose from
Google and the strategy that we
implemented for cloud migration and also
we'll look at our migration plans
I'm sorry it took a while for that to
pick up so what we want is are the
things that we saw from our challenges
and Bobby chose is what I'm gonna talk
in detail so what we needed was a highly
scalable and reliable infrastructure our
scaling needs our spiky at times when we
send out a breaking news alert we have
to scale up pretty quick to serve that
traffic and it could be like an
event-based
scale up like the scaling needs were
like BSF of events to like if we were to
like we are hosting an a an event like
politic elections our Olympics maybe any
special event we had to scale up our
infrastructure for that what we needed
is to build apps that could rely on
reliable infrastructure like GCS big
very big table and gke they all have
published essays and they are pretty
much reliable so we chose to work with
these services that are managed by
Google and they mentioned that we wanted
to be fast the way we wanted to be fast
is by bringing autonomy in managing
environments for the developers or they
experienced over the years of experience
what we found is dollar purse are more
knowledgeable about managing their
application in case of an outage or
shipping that huge configuration change
that can it could make a lot of impact
so what we chose was to use TCP projects
as a tool to provide that autonomy and
give developers or give developers the
full access to their own environments
and help them manage their own
infrastructures in production
at the time when we were in our data
centers we saw how containers couldn't
help maybe for scaling or maybe for you
know making a parody between your dev
stage environments and we wanted to
adopt container technology as a main
scale way of deploying and building and
deploying applications to production at
the time we evaluated with we were
evaluating container orchestration
services like marathon missiles no man
and kubernetes in the end
as a company we decided to adopt
kubernetes as our container our
castration service but if we were to
build and manage kubernetes
infrastructure for the entire company
then the delivery engineering team which
is a small team a number would have been
in you know dealing with just managing
the nodes and clusters and patching them
on whatnot so when Google came out with
manage kubernetes
service which is gke it was quite easy
for us to double down on G and GCP and
GK and rely on Google to manage our
infrastructure that is the proven area's
infrastructure so what we were looking
at was a true engineering partner who
could provide services and support for
building applications and as well as
even run those applications for us so so
we chose or gke services what we want to
work with but we had to build up a
strategy for Migration the way how we
saw our strategy was to build on it's
not just like lift and shift but lean on
to the shift more a meaning shift the
processes that we were working with that
is our culture and the tooling that
supports this migration so we wanted to
shape the process culture and tooling
such shifting processes um as I
mentioned we gave TCP projects as a way
to provide development teams and
autonomy in managing their own
infrastructure but what that really
meant was teams would know what they
owned and in their GCP projects and and
their destiny of those services - we
moved away from this culture of having
an ops team that would manage their
applications in production to developers
owning their services end-to-end so
that's a culture shift Avedon
in traditionally we we were working off
of ticket based system and we wanted to
change that by building automation that
are common across multiple teams and run
projects by just using off-the-shelf
tools like g-cloud and cube guru or cube
control whatever and we wrote
documentation we build a lot of
centralized documentation and
step-by-step guides to onboard teams to
the the automation that that engineering
built and in helping in helping them
manage their infrastructure so we
basically moved away from ticket based
traditional infrastructure way of
handling paths that are common between
application deployments to much more
self-service moral of building
automation that solved these common
tasks so as we were migrating we also
saw that we were going into a different
land altogether from data center to GCP
not every team was aware of how
kubernetes work or what GCP services
could do so we had to build a lot of
training we engaged with Google and to
get a lot of teams around how kubernetes
gke could be employed to build and
deploy their applications and so on so
what we did here is build those
transferable skills the culture shift is
yes there is projects there there are
applications are a building but we
needed to build that consistency in the
way how these teams could work with
those environments the way how we did
that which is training like we build
those transferable skills on teams so if
an engineer were to move from one team
to another team they would be
comfortable in understanding that
environment
culture shift in the way how we manage
our CI CD processes so I gave a little
bit of an insight into everybody gets a
project and they're off their own and
they they can configure whatever they
want but the way how we wanted to bring
consistency in in managing these
environments is by building automation
around CI CD so we adapted drone a
container based deployment tool to help
deploy applications well the ship that
we came out of is we were not setting up
billboards with the config management
tool with Jenkins and teams don't have
to go back and forth all we have is just
a Yama file where their pipeline is
described as cold and V as delivery
engineering team provided that yeah Mel
file has a template so teams could
extend that template and deploy their
app so we made a shift from writing
configuration management code for
building app building will bots and
completely on container technology
withdrawn so drone and github are
integrated and if there is a git push
then drone kicks in and deploys to
wherever it has two secrets it's a big
topic when we were in our data center
there are various ways teams used to
manage their secrets it could be good
clip or it could be puppet Hirayama so
there were various ways and obviously
that led to secret secret sprawl we
wanted to tackle that by deploying what
has she got wall wall is a single tool
that had been integrated into our github
and drone so every team gets a secrets
back in space for wall we call it
namespace and teams can write their
secrets depending on
they're repositories and push those
secrets into their namespaces without
having to model with other other team
secrets so a bit one today we have about
like 75 namespaces weird and and the way
how we integrate that is if if teams
have to build and deploy new
environments wall can completely take
care of these secrets and apply to those
environments so we've adapted wall and
policies of managing wall is also put
into gift so we use policy management as
code with wall now
when we were in our data center we used
to have physical networking routing
equipment like knit scalars and also we
had a varnish monolith layer there we
used to pull create pull requests and it
was becoming like a monolith huge
monolith that that was taking our
routing layer into a unmanageable state
what we did was we adapted fastly we
made that routing layer into much more
modular eyes components that teams can
own and manage their own routing routing
routes in in terms of writing of ECL
code so we moved away from this ticket
based model of changing route routing
path to modernizing and making it an
e-code way of handling handling the
routing logic fast adapting fast leave
you also achieved a I would say in a
much more important feature is what we
did during the migration will be wrote
we wrote logic to split the traffic to
applications in GCP and by a percentage
basis like say 5% of the traffic would
go to GCP applications understand how
that traffic pattern would affect that
application and learn about these
services in GCB and move on and cut over
to maybe 50% or 70% and test out how
they have behaved with the modifications
that we were making to fit GCP and
gradually we cut over from data center
to GCP with fastly
cause when we move from a data center to
Klout cost is an important thing for us
all of our operational costs in the data
center were budgeted in a single budget
so teams really didn't know or had to
look into the operational cost of each
application but when we gave GCP
projects teams have to have visibility
into how much resources that they are
using in the cloud what we did is we
delivery engineering build a budget but
that basically alerts teams about allow
its alerts team about the budgets that
they have set for the projects so people
can set budgets in AML file as you can
see here they're sending alerts for ten
percent twenty fifty percent or 50
percent or 75 percent so the mod
basically sends a slack notification
when the GCP project hit those budgets
are thresholds so we just codified our
made budgets in the phone overall our
shift in the way how we use tooling and
culture now looks like this most of our
work is the top space github base your
code and pipeline as code and
infrastructure as code with gke and GAE
and also managing your secrets and
managing your policies for secrets is
also now infrastructure has code it's
tied into that notion so basically if
you are at a loop where all you do is
get come in push and drawn desk you
apply onto the GCP projects and pushes
code into the environments so it's much
more simpler and consistent across the
projects
so now I talked about the services we
chose strategy we used in the way of how
we shifted our data center applications
into GCP I'm going to talk about how we
executed our migration so when we were
strategizing and developing tools around
a year and a half ago New York Times
decided to shut down our data centers by
q1 of 2018 and we didn't extend our
leases so we had to meet those deadlines
that's the situation we were basically
our planning was on four major
components that I will hit this is a
networking data application and
monitoring needs so those are the four
pillars that I will cover for as a
migration and transition plans so like
coming from a data center of mindset or
you all would have had this experience
most of your apps need physical network
in a way how they connect with each
other but as I mentioned we were going
into a plane where all applications are
going to be in individual GCP projects
and we started trying out fewer
networking models to solve for the
connectivity the main connecting the
connect connections that we needed or
our data center to GCP project by a GCP
project in a hub-and-spoke model where
there would be a direct connection from
a centralized hub project where we would
host our infrastructure services like
DNS and expand that with VPN tunnels to
other GCP projects we experimented with
that and then we quickly realized that
there are limitations on how many VPN
tunnels that you could connect with on a
GC and a single TCP project and we
couldn't move forward with the
hub-and-spoke model and then we started
looking into VPN mesh networking to
connect all the GCP projects with each
other whenever there is a connection
that's needed with VPN tunnels even that
didn't scale well because it was
becoming a lot of overhead for our team
to maintain these connections and make
sure
the VPN tunnels are healthy and whatnot
so finally we met with Google we went
through our needs what we needed was a
way to have our data center services
exposed to the services that are getting
deployed in GCP so we achieve that using
cloud endpoints how many of you here are
aware of Cloud endpoints have you
experimented with Cloud endpoints that's
quite a few all right
Cloud endpoints is a proxy that is built
by Google I would highly recommend
there's not many people that raise their
hands I'm aware of support endpoints
mine
but one thing I would say is this true
does this prove to be a solution we
could use I would highly recommend
looking at the way how Cloud endpoints
can be deployed but what it is is
generally a it's it's a container engine
X container that Google provides and it
has authentication it can help you
provide authentication against your
services that don't have earth right now
so we use Cloud endpoints to deploy in
our projects GCP projects to have
connection between project to project on
at zero trust network and that is the
Google's way the pools prescribed way is
to implement TLS encryption everywhere
and beyond zero trust network
we also deployed the same Cloud
endpoints Google's call set as extended
service proxy if you deployed that
external service proxy in our data
centers to expose the services that are
in our data centers to the project and
services that are in multiple DCP
projects so that's how our network had
transformed from a physical VPN network
to a zero trust TLS encrypted based
Network I also we started moving away
from firewalls we rely on I am rules to
limit access is between services
data not all of our migrations were
dumped on load what we did is we started
syncing data to GCS bucket and migrate
or data to services that are managed by
Google like bigquery BigTable datastore
cloud sequel and spanner it required
little bit of rewriting but we first
migrated our data syncing them into
these abstractions and we started
cutting over slowly so not all were
dumped on load but some of them were so
I mentioned our strategy was to use gke
GAE services that are managed by Google
and our planning we made sure that most
of our apps have migrated to those
abstractions then going into a VM based
models where teams have to manage the
VMS this particularly help does in the
migration because teams were just
focusing on the features and Google was
managing their infrastructure for them
so the transition was much faster for us
and what it did was the by providing
that consistent automation that drone
gave we converted all of our apps you
fit into GK eg a morrow and fall
factorizing them like I said we
standardize our pipelines and we use
Google deployment manager and terraform
to set up the basic infrastructure that
is needed before the deployments began
how many of you here are working with
more than one monitoring logging tool
here Wow I usually teams often ask for
that specific monitoring tool that they
like and in new york times we ended up
having a slew of monitoring and logging
tools as part of our migration we wanted
to reduce that number what we didn't
have is a default or standard way of
setting monitoring reports or dashboards
for alerts so what we started doing is
to rely on Google strata ever for
setting up that basic monitoring and
alerting that we have to provide today
we have slack and pages UT integration
with instructure Iver and every
application has a basic dashboard that
we could any any team member could go
and look at and understand they wrestle
eyes so I talked about a lot of strategy
execution it's all great but what we
noticed is teams are at various levels
of operational maturity so we had to up
our game over there and I was hand over
to deep to talk about operational
maturity
so yeah like Prashant talked about like
the process of the migration it says but
a great part of this was building
operational maturity into our practices
and like and on the teams that were
actually going to build and maintain
these applications so we realized very
early on a special mention like not all
development teams are at the same level
of maturity like we had teams that were
absolutely thrilled at the prospect of
being in the cloud and like having all
the autonomy and wanting to build
everything from scratch versus teams
that just wanted to build their little
nodejs app and just like have it
deployed somewhere in the cloud or just
write application features but not
really worry about operations so I think
we had to level set very early on with a
lot of these teams and we realized that
during the migrations a lot of these
teams would will need a lot of support
so fish aren't mentioned all the all the
trainings that we did all the
documentation that we wrote like you
know setting up the writing like right
level of support was very very important
and one of the biggest things we talked
about with teams was being on call like
making sure that you know we are giving
teams a lot of autonomy to run their
infrastructure in the cloud but at the
same time it comes with some level of
responsibility the level of
responsibility is around managing costs
also managing their uptime and there s
allies in SL O's on an ongoing basis
there was not going to be a central
infrastructure team or a centralized
system team going forward to to actually
manage the uptime for their apps and
also be on-call for those apps so one of
the things we did was every time someone
wanted to someone decided that they were
going to move to the cloud and they came
up with a plan we would kick that we
would kick that off with application
readiness reviews just to assess where
the team and the application are from a
maturity standpoint it was very
important for us to do so we started
doing with doing it with certain teams
and then other teams just jumped on it
and said oh well we also want to move to
the cloud like can you have
but assess where we are and what we need
to work on and like the idea was to
identify gaps not just from a technical
standpoint but also for us to understand
for our team to understand where we will
need to provide support and how much
support will these teams need we also
instituted regular office hours where
people could come and talk to us about
random questions but at the same time
what the office hours did was it it
served as a community building exercise
of sorts like like people from multiple
teams would show up and talk about their
issues and then find solutions to each
other's problems as a part of it which
was excellent because that sort of took
us out of the picture and like the teams
were actually talking to each other and
also sort of put our engineers in front
of the Google Technical Account Managers
and like the Google customer engineers
that were embedded with us for for the
course of the migration was really
really helpful
thank you Jim Rami Asscher very much so
and of course like you know they were
there it was it was a shared fate for
both us as well as Google so they were
there to support our steering our major
launches during our major migrations etc
and just before you decide to switch
over to production in the cloud let's do
a production assessment make sure that
you have all the things that you need
make sure that you are your that you're
ready you're like for air for a calamity
or like you know in case you have to
fall back to the data center for a while
what the plan for that is so just how
doing a production readiness review was
very important we don't we we read this
book right like this is where most of
our ideas came from
I wish we had written that book but like
I did but yeah like the idea was
evangelize reliability as a feature like
to to us it was very important that
people understand that all the features
that you built into your product are
great but at the same time if you do not
prioritize reliability of your apps as a
feature it can all go to waste very
quickly like it only takes like four
spinning wheels and
on an app for me to uninstall that app
and I'm gay I'm guessing a lot of other
people are maybe as impatient as I am or
maybe a lot less patient than I am so to
me it's very important that you know
reliability is considered a feature so
it's not something that often
afterthought that you you think about
and that was a big cultural culture
shift where team started thinking about
building more and more reliability into
their apps monitoring their SL eyes and
like you know tracking their s ellos etc
and like you know sharing them across
across the board so like one if if a
team knew that it was a dependency for
many other teams it was very important
for them to build their as aloes and
share it with other teams that's
something that we did through the course
of the migration we worked with Google's
customer reliability engineering team
Nick is here thank you so much for all
your help they came in trained some of
our teams they also provided us with a
template of assessments that we allow
that we work with teams on and say like
you know these are some of the things
that you need to think about when you're
trying to build more reliability into
your applications and allows us to have
the conversations that the CRE team add
with us very very early on in the
process and then of course like you know
as a part of the assessment you can
score high or low on certain aspects of
your reliability matrix and you know we
make sure that that work that you need
to do to build more reliability entirely
your applications are tracked on an
ongoing basis so that it doesn't get
lost or this is all work that comes
together and when it comes together it's
really nice and I mentioned being on
call this to us was probably the biggest
culture shift so on calls freaks people
out sometimes like it it used to freak
me out it doesn't anymore because we
have a we have built a lot of maturity
around on call but the initial
nervousness is very hard to overcome and
we have to go have conversations with a
lot of teams and a lot of engineers who
are very very nervous about what happens
if I get called in the middle of the
night and I don't know how to fix the
problem so the idea is to build more
confidence in your processes so that
your engineers your developers can feel
more confident when being on call we ask
teams to develop play books run books
solutions to common problems that could
be shared across the board perform war
games like which is sight out in
simulations that people can work through
and actually build more confidence in
their abilities to support an
application when they are actually going
on call and it continues to be an
ongoing conversations with with teams to
build more and more operational maturity
so some of the lessons learnt through
this whole process as Prashant mentioned
was do not try to replicate your data
center setups in the cloud sometimes it
will work sometimes it won't be very
very aware of what what it means to run
in the in a public cloud and what are
some of the constraints that comes with
or what are some of the constraints of
your data centers that may not be
constraints in the public cloud a
networking journey was actually a very
very good learning learning example for
for a lot of people we we tried our best
to work against the fabric of Google and
that didn't work out it was just not the
way Google wanted us to build absent
which is fine like you know go Google's
not of we I I personally would tell my
team like Google Google is not a vendor
for us they're a partner they have done
this they've actually figured out how to
run applications services and and sites
at scale this is an opportunity for not
just them to learn from us but us to
learn from Google as well so treat them
as a partner figure out what are the
best practices for your cloud provider
in this case Google to actually run your
applications their review your
application architecture connectivity
depending
like there were times when we had an app
running in Google as well as our data
center with certain certain downstream
apps using the Google side of things
certain downstream apps using the data
center side or like you know an app that
didn't have enough confidence in that
GCP set up still having the data center
as a fallback and then gradually
increasing the traffic as they built
more maturity in the cloud so continue
to load test the assumptions you make
and when you're running in your data
center may not hold true when you're
running in the cloud you may need more
computing many less compute you may need
more memory like think things like that
are important so continue to benchmark
your applications during the course of
the migration or in general it's a great
thing to continue to benchmark your apps
through course of releases and like you
know deployments etc one of the things
that we did early on was manage a
centralized launch calendar that so
teams are aware of their dependencies
and were always aware of when their
dependencies would be moving to the
cloud or like when their dependencies
would be ready in the cloud so they
could they could actually coordinate
with their dependencies or like that
depending systems depending systems
would be able to talk to their dependent
systems again I talked about the CRE
engagement like you know it was
invaluable for us to have access to Nick
and his team and it continues to be
invaluable for us it's been amazing for
us to interact with them learn from them
and bring their practices back to the
teams that we work with in terms of
what's next we want to continue
educating teams educating ourselves and
SRE
best practices we we want to employ
those across the board so for that we
want to build tools instrument metrics
in a common way so that we are we're
always talking the same language we want
to build organization wide SLO
dashboards so that we are always aware
of what's going on like you know
observability is important to us
especially
a new site that's that that that relies
on very high uptime news cycles are our
spiky news can happen anytime you want
to make sure that we are building a lot
more reliability into our our
applications so we can provide the most
benefit to our readers we want to I
mentioned test automation very early on
it's a fairly new practice that we are
adopting but at the same like what we
want to do is make sure that automation
is a first-class citizen in all CIC the
pipelines that we build so provide
tooling for us to embed functional tests
and to n test load tests within our CIC
D pipelines so we can run them as a part
of every deployment or or at the or on
demand and while we do this we want to
celebrate our successes so that's one of
the things we are doing here is actually
talking about some of our successes we
want we've learnt a lot from it we want
everyone else to learn from it as well
and if any of this sounds interesting to
you please come join us we are hiring
you know we we want to work with smart
people people who we can learn from so
so it's always always interesting we
always talk about our experiences on the
on the open blog that we publish so yeah
that that's that's pretty much it
okay then thank you everyone and we are
here if you want to talk to us like
comes in come to come talk to us these
are the people from the New York Times
over here over there please come talk to
all of us thank you
[Music]